the vengers having impossibly exactly
I am Maximo from FX guide.com for wired
the Avengers returned in age of Ultron
and we visited ILM in San Francisco to
talk to the team behind the digital
Ultron and of course the Hulk it was a
good opportunity to build on what they
done on the first Avengers Hulk was well
realized in that film for sure but the
challenge coming into this was ok well
how can we improve upon it here make it
better and so we pretty much rebuild him
entirely
ILM developed a new approach to facial
animation and muscle system that
involved a sub mesh on top of the muscle
shapes more like a facial skin layer
interestingly Mark Ruffalo was given a
monster mirror preview setup which used
a laptop and a camera and allowed him to
do a real-time Mark Ellis facial
tracking system to a real-time model of
the Hulk this allowed him to experiment
with the character and prepare for his
onset performance the system literally
showed a Hulk version of mark back to
mark in real time some of the motion
capture was done with Ruffalo prior to
the shoot and some was done on set with
a helmet cam and grey suit so that mark
could interact with the other Avenger
actors in this scene with Black Widow
Mark Ruffalo actually wore cricket
gloves so that Scarlett Johansson had
something roughly the right size to
touch well I think we paved the ground
with Avengers 1 you know it was very
well received in terms of his
performance and his believability we
took that as a challenge of we can make
it better we revamp the entire model
including the facial shapes and really
kind of matching the intent that we saw
from Mark Ruffalo when he was on set or
pushing it to where jaws needed to for
the comic action beats we explored
definitely making it more in that comic
realm we pushed how far he can open his
jaw it's almost this one is dislocated
in some cases as with Avengers 1 ILM
needed to build a digital Hulk and a
digital Mark Ruffalo with I am using an
approach started with the
Davy Jones character in the pirates
movies to the facial animation that is
to say the animators would visually
match to Ruffalo's performance but then
Island would run an automatic simulation
over the top this would provide the
right kind of flesh sim and movement the
inertia for the Hulk
Mark Ruffalo was on set but the team
also had a bodybuilder rob de Groot who
was painted green for lighting and
muscle reference initially Hulk was
actually planned to turn gray when he's
angry Hulk in the Hulkbuster sequence
but hey everybody wanted the green guy
so in the end I am just changed his eyes
to make them look more sullen when he's
under the control of Scarlet Witch well
please subscribe for more behind the
scenes action I'm Mike Seymour for Wired